foreign
[Music]
So today we're going to be talking about
metadata at scale and we've got Matt
Bruno with me yeah I'm Ryan McLean
obviously just a quick background on
myself in terms of like why this matters
to me so prior to working at datadog I
worked at Samsung so in terms of the
skill that we had tagging was a really
important issue or problem to have but
also something that really enabled us to
go through our day-to-day operations
what about yourself match
yeah so I've been living the
transformation life for a while so
before Wayfair I was at EMC in Dell
we're going through our own
transformation piece there so how you
manage these things at scale for large
companies going through these
super topical
excited to talk about it here all right
let's get into it so first I'll give you
a quick blurb about datadog for those of
you who haven't heard of data before
I'll make it really short I promise but
datadog is a monitoring and analytics
platform it provides full visibility
across your organization so that's
spanning end to end from your
infrastructure and network to
applications and services all the way to
your end users what I'd like to say is
that the idea is to enable everyone
that's Ops Dev security and even folks
in the business to have a shared
understanding of your systems that's
your applications and how your business
looks from a technology perspective so
in short basically what we want to be is
that single platform for all of your
observability needs
which brings us nicely to Wayfarer we
are a single platform for all things
home
we've got a big e-commerce platform with
a lot of In-House technology focused on
both the supplier experience and the
customer experience which leads to a
huge deal of scale and complexity on the
back end now if you're not familiar we
do operate a number of Brands some of
them omnichannel with physical retail
and online but we are primarily
e-commerce right with a full in-house
Tech footprint not to belabor it too
much but it kind of leads into the
technical complexity we'll be talking
about here you know our customer reaches
on the scale of billions of Impressions
across North America and parts of Europe
with a full Suite of website and app on
the side
Logistics wise we've built out a whole
carrier Network right that's been a huge
differentiator for us and obviously
leads to a large scale right because we
are managing
millions of products moving all across
the world at this point so keeping that
tracked end-to-end has been a huge
technical challenge but it's been an
exciting one to really be able to build
in-house
um and drive a real competitive
Advantage there you know lastly we
talked really the shopping experience
and what our customers see which is
going to be leading Us in here
we have millions and millions of
products so managing that catalog and
managing all of this pieces on the back
end drive us here so start with the site
now looks pretty straightforward I'm
sure we've all seen the e-commerce site
before kind of what I'd call attention
to here though is since we're managing
our own pricing Network our own
Logistics Network all the different
elements you see there are different
back of house systems right so for my
day-to-day job of keeping the site
running if one of those goes bump it's a
question of you know which needle in the
haystack caused it which to lead into
our at scale tag and conversation here
wow our footprint yeah our footprint
before we start tagging anything it's I
got a few Haystacks out there
um and those red dots do not necessarily
mean something's bad so I'm kind of at
this challenge of how do I manage this
so cool we got there we're in the cloud
we are at scale what next right which
brings us into the metadata piece and
I'd say you know Ryan why is this
important yeah it's a good question so I
like to think a lot of times about
incentives goals or maybe like why
you're doing something so to me tagging
feels like a bit of hygiene so you can
kind of think of maybe delayed
gratification what I mean by that is
let's say you're going to the dentist
and they tell you to floss tell you the
floss in fact the last time I went they
told me that flossing is way more
important than brushing and I like to
think of these sort of governance
problems very similar so it's something
that you're going to set up now to help
your future self so when you're awakened
at 2 am what have your databases down
that's probably not the time to tag
things maybe you can post event but what
you want to do is beforehand do that for
you in fact it'd be awful if you went to
do something like drop a table in debt
when you thought it was prod this can be
pretty sticky and having been involved
in those incidents before I think that
can be a problem so the incentive here
is to help your future self your future
team or your company down the road for
things like governance it could be
around cost centers or general ledgers
or maybe something around security those
kind of things will actually help you
now basically if you do it now it's
going to help you later so it's hard to
think about it's hard to like maybe give
you an incentive like oh yeah future me
will like this but when you are on call
and it comes down to the wire it is
really important to know what you're
looking at to be able to find that
needle in a stack especially at scale
because those small problems become very
very important at scale when you're
dealing with hundreds thousands tens or
millions of holes it can be very
difficult to sort through and figure out
now this is this is kind of a long
overview but basically the tags are a
way of helping you use multiple
Dimensions sorry to look at your
infrastructure your metrics your traces
your logs to help you with those because
it can be really hard when there's like
an inflection point and you want to see
hey where did this come from what what
caused this
which brings us nicely to we're talking
about a scary of going from a monolithic
application to really decoupled micro
Services we go more Cloud native but if
we go back in time and we talk the
limitation of where we were right you
talk the limitation of raw time series
metrics and you say okay on a monolith
you see a latency Spike cool you've got
one deploy train that audit list of what
might have changed what I need to know
the dimensionalities you said you know
it's it's a lot more narrow and it's a
lot easier and this worked for a number
of years for us and then you hit a
Tipping Point we say okay well you've
actually got what we had about 5000
micro Services behind the scenes now so
you're talking about that scale and it's
well if this goes bump at the top level
for the user experience there's nothing
in there that tells me exactly which
piece of this broke behind the scenes so
the first part of our story is on how we
get into distributed tracing to really
tackle it but to tie it into the idea of
metadata and tagging to keep all of
those traces aligned to the correct span
to be able to really stitch together
that user Journey you need to be
injecting the right metadata at every
step of the line and you need the
consistent distribution so you know
start voicing over what we've really
done to tackle some of those scale
challenges first a big piece and you
talk about you know doing your future
self a favor is go out and standardize
the deployments right so when we have
tracing distributed we needed to make
sure it was set up the same for every
language we support and we
I think there's somewhere in the 8 to 10
range of like production supported
languages right now and for a long time
we had to sort of pointed people at the
raw libraries and said hey this is how
you set it up good luck have fun and it
it works for a while but then you get to
that point of scale where well those
traces aren't actually getting stitched
together because you're tagging them
differently so we went back to the
drawing board and standardized across
all the language libraries to say okay
now you have this unified picture so in
our lovely generic piece here when you
say do some work we actually know what
that unit of work is
now to make this a little more real to
our experience go back to you know
effectively the same shopping page we
had up before you know I yeah I think it
shows up pretty well on the screen here
so there's different color boxes
highlight the different parts of the
journey the different core domains that
are at play here and that starts to give
us a little more control over it so when
you're talking operability when you're
talking runtime governance I can now
start to break this down and know who's
doing what and how the whole piece fits
together and obviously if you have that
latency Spike you're probably not seeing
it across the entire stack you're seeing
it for a specific service so maybe our
Logistics Services running a little slow
so my shipping estimate is lagging it's
holding the page up or maybe the header
bar is being a little wonky because of a
deploy but when you get a little more
nuanced if you have the changes tagged
to the piece of infrastructure that
you're monitoring a piece of software
that you're monitoring it's a lot faster
to make those correlations in there and
out Ryan I believe you've got some
overview for us here yeah for sure so I
guess what we're talking about when
we're looking at that needle and the
Haystacks some of these tags that we're
talking about and we're saying tags but
metadata in general it could be labels
and kubernetes it could be a tag for an
instance it could also be something like
a grouping in gcp but what we mean by
this metadata is that things that will
percolate or bubble up for us to be able
to say hey it came from here then it
went to here that kind of thing so if we
look at this graph we could do it from
top down if we're trying to figure out
which service we're talking about so
obviously in this graph we're looking at
service C it's got a lot more data about
it but if we start from the bottom what
we want to know is hey is this in prod
is this in Dev which environment is this
actual problem in because that's going
to be key do I need to wake up at 2AM
because it's a Dev problem do I need to
wake up at 2 because it's a staging
problem if it's production probably and
then the next is like which zone is this
in because you might have different
names for different areas but it's
important for you to know where to look
as well and then of course the cloud
provider is going to be gcp and then
going up from there we're going to look
at what kind of orchestration deployed
this was there a recent deploy can I
check out those pipelines can I use use
this tag to sort of follow back and
figure out what the the provenance I
guess is of this actual problem where
did it stem from and then I guess going
a little bit to the right is it
serverless is it on a VM what sort of
infrastructure is it using is this
something that Google's managing is this
something that I bravely decided to
manage on my own or is this something
that's a hosted cloud service so in this
case like the dependency is cloud SQL
MySQL and then I only released too much
but basically which function it is which
hosts it on which container is it I
guess what I'm really trying to say is
that there are a lot of Dimensions so
for those of you I realize generative AI
is a big deal right now these are only
three dimensions I think in that space
you might have multi-dimensionality and
we're trying to keep this simple here so
something like the instance type and the
availability is on will be things that
Google will give you in terms of
metadata but also you might want to
think of and this is oversimplification
I apologize but the role so in 3D we can
think of these three axes for example
and using those we can say which of
these instances have which tags apply to
them but role is just one example I
mentioned cost center before I mentioned
general ledger before but there's also
things like which Port are open or which
Security Group might this be tagged with
or what kind of networking is this tag
with or maybe we're looking at sort of
business areas of grouping tagging
metadata what kind of data can we give
to the business that will help us
determine what actual Services is and
why it's important to us
and to really use that you had up before
and you say when we want to try and
solve that Rubik's Cube that you just
presented right you know what does that
look like for us in production we've
really got two core Dimensions we're
looking at you know first we have our
technical owners what team owns the
infrastructure who do I chase down for
better or worse I see a lot of teams up
there that I am accountable for so that
is my lovely piece of the puzzle but
then you also have what's the business
function what are those pieces doing and
you're starting to get those two angles
of it here and those are distinctly
different so when you talk about scaling
when you talk about cost management it's
important to have those tags there
because you can choose how you want to
slice and dice it you know and we've
lived it right we pivot from having a
team-based hierarchy to looking more at
what's the business function and how do
you tie it back and say okay this
experience actually costs this much
what's the return on investment there
and then you can start to optimize a lot
more and you can start to dig in and do
a bit more in the way of apples dapple's
comparisons and well I've got these two
things they're solving similar business
challenges one of them costs twice as
much why well if you have it tagged
correctly you can kind of get that
direct comparison there to see what's
going on
pulling this in a bit more to a runtime
governance piece and we start talking
about our favorite thing in the world
slos but to really manage these pieces
at scale you very much need to be
tracking what are those agreements
between services and so you start
stitching that as the next Dimension you
say okay well I know what business
functions are doing based on the tags
and you can chase that back to some of
the Spandau that we showed earlier we
can say what calls what but that doesn't
matter if you don't know what to expect
from each other right and so that's
where being able to set the slos in is
kind of that last piece of runtime
governance that really matters to enable
this
um and I think that's been a challenge
for us right as we rolled out at scale
you know we were good at tagging and
splitting things down but then you go
back and say okay well we built all
these things based on a web of
assumptions and that works to get you
somewhere quickly I don't think it's
fundamentally the wrong thing
but as you get up to scale and you talk
about okay how do we actually drive
stability at this point you need to go
back to basics and say okay for the
whole experience what are our targets
and then as you step down per each
domain for each business function and
to keep it tied in by having those tags
you can go slice and dice and I think
it's an important piece to say your
objectives are based on reality you know
there's no point in saying I'm going to
have this super tight window that I'm
targeting if
pale it's way out of whack so you know
we can talk about the four nines the
five nines I think I've heard that
mentioned a few other conversations here
this week if you're really just at two
and a half and that might be good enough
because you're still talking about you
know only a few hours a month of
disruption which is a fair change window
off hours that's the right way to place
it
I think there's also an angle here about
you know how did we get there how are we
able to enable it we talked about
standardizing our language libraries
another piece and you touched on this a
minute ago is keeping those tags unified
keeping that metadata unified you know
because it's datadog and Google have
slightly different labeling requirements
so what we did to solve that we went out
and built a metadata Handler service oh
that's cool yeah so that's something
that's now a sidecar in all our deploy
pipelines so you roll your code out
whichever pieces of metadata you
populated will then pull it in true it
up and make sure that Dash is an
underscore is sort of aligned correctly
but when we're doing any sort of
governance on the back end that lets us
really stitch together and be able to
associate those pieces
so we certainly found that it's an
interesting thing that we ran into kind
of halfway through
I believe you've got some best practices
for us yeah for sure so I think we're
touching on a little bit of consistency
there so I'm assuming that those in the
audience has come across like is this
the dev environment is this the
development environment is that all caps
does it start with a capital D what does
it look like and even the environment
tag itself you'll find in some shops
they might just shorten that to do EnV
or Capital ENB it really depends and
others there's different ways of coping
with I think the Eno service is a really
good approach to actually get at this to
sort of deal with the Legacy systems
that you've got but there's also maybe
once you realize that there's a problem
there's like a policy standard procedure
or infrastructure as code that you can
do as well to get it but in the interim
I feel like those kind of services that
you have in the house really help
because there's a deployment time
there's Dev time obviously but what you
want to do is start standardizing this
soon before it becomes a governance
problem so if you do it up front I think
that's a lot easier so I'm kind of
skipping a little bit ahead here but in
terms of like start four starting small
I think I started playing for starting
small is really important and the sooner
you start the better and then we were
talking a little bit about that
consistency already but I think
sometimes in some of Matt's graphs we
saw like who are the owners so who
actually owns this service which group
does it belong to how can they get
access to these Services what's
important to them when they're on call
and trying to figure out what actually
happened or where do you attribute this
cost or maybe how to look down this path
in order to figure out where the
security problem is so it does become
maybe more of a governance challenge
down the road and it's something that
you can do now to help that future self
to give you that delayed gratification
basically to say hey I've done this
essentially these these tasks all the
way and then when it comes down when the
metal when the rubber beats the road you
can actually go in and find the problems
for you and then again at the very
bottom here when we're talking about
things that multiple purposes so that
can allow you to do those cost tracking
automation organization
steps basically this will help you out
are there any of these that stick out
for you and
it's like the day-to-day yeah I mean
obviously the multiple purpose is you
know for cost tracking has been huge
because you start you say okay well
maybe you know what a team does and
maybe you know what a department does
but how do you Stitch that together you
know has been a challenge and I think
it's one of the topical pieces right
because we all race in the new tech sac
and it's something to be said for move
fast and get there to start driving the
business results but then how do you
show it back after the fact and really
balance the books on it you know and
obviously my world for operations it's
ah something went bump in the night you
know why you know I think for that
assigning the owners is a deceptively
tricky case and you know just to reflect
on it we've been through a few different
ways of defining owners for a while we
had technical owner business owner
support owner or on-call owner and
somehow those lists ended up being a
little bit different and that's a piece
where the more we started to parse
students okay well why why are those
different we found what we're just
pulling from different data sources and
we're not doing you know to keep harping
back to it not making our future lives
Easier by not standardizing at the front
end so we then went through and did a
bit of a refactor on that you know have
a bit of a rethink we said okay
this should be a lot simpler if you own
the thing you need to be empowered to
fix it and that actually drives some of
the tool and roadmap for on the
operation side what we look to enable
you know how can we enable workflow
automation for teams to fix their own
problems
why we do that becomes a little more
obvious when you start to uncover those
problems okay well I shouldn't have to
pick which of the four teams that owns
this thing I need to go reach out to
like that needs to be a one one-time
answer I mean I don't know about you if
I get woken up at two in the morning I'm
the brain cells aren't all there
definitely they get there but
so simplifying those answers makes that
governance piece easier and I think it's
one of those things when you talk about
the scale aspect of it if you're not
setting yourselves up for Success those
things that were easy and that oh you
just knew the guy who knew the guy who
owned that thing two years ago that kind
of runs away from you on a hurry and all
of a sudden you're looking back and
saying I don't even know what team these
people are on I don't know I don't know
where to chase it down
I think if you get yourself into that 2
A.M game of telephone not that people
aren't happy to get online and help but
when you're five people deep trying to
figure out who owns a domain that's not
a great place to be so really figuring
out how you want to Define ownership and
who you need in the mix is important and
that's you know paying the dividends for
yourself down the line so that
Allen's near and dear just because we
went through that exercise a couple
times over in the last year and I think
coming out the other side it feels like
an oaha moment it seems super obvious
but it's it's not and it's worth putting
some of the effort in up front and that
leads into the runtime governance when
you're setting slos and then it gets
easier okay
who do I pull into the room to figure
out what the Agreements are going to be
here well I know who owns these two
things and I'm not trying to figure out
who there are double secret owner is
it's straight up this is the team that I
reach out to they can come and tell me
what their actual boundary conditions
are what they can provide
same point you obviously get back on
cost governance so I know you asked me
for one and I gave you two but no that's
great jump out of me I think that's
really important trying to figure out
where that edge is so if you've got a
Venn diagram of like one team and
another team there could be some overlap
on that edge so it's important to know
where that handoff is or what might be a
sure concern between two teams yeah no
exactly I mean we can hop back a few
slides if we want to if we dare try to
see how the back buttons working say go
one or two more so we talk about
breaking down the site by those actual
domain it's going way too far back but
my apologies this one right here yeah
this works so you talk about the
handoffs between those teams and how we
try and Chase it down you know I think
that's a
don't want to give me I like the buttons
too much
and you talk about the handoffs between
these teams that's where having those
clear domain boundaries helps and I
think that's really the the flex point
between these two slides business
function provides a little more value
here and when you talk about how you
treat this out especially in a more
microservice based architecture right
one of the debates we're honestly
happening now
tagged me by microservice is one thing
but looking at the actual application
and roll up those are generally your
boundaries and then what happens within
it is it's not fungible but that's you
know for the team that owns it to figure
out and have the expertise on
so this view it looks a little scarier
because there are you know more dots
more grouping it's actually calming
because that's I know where the
boundaries are between all our different
functions
it's the exact demarcations you step
back through say okay now when I'm
setting the slos right that's the edge
I'm setting it on
gotcha now on our end I think there's a
couple tags that are important to us
just as a vendor but I think they might
be if you're not digital clients might
be important to you too so we've got
application or app then we'll have
service so like which micro service is
important to you and then the last one
is kind of that version so which which
version of this software is that you're
deploying and of course Google provides
us with a bunch of tags already the
metadata will come from the cloud
integration so we get things like the
region The Zone what kind of
infrastructure that you're actually
using with Google and maybe the
environment as well that you will have
tagged when you put it up to Google and
combining all of these tags together
will allow you to get that that
visibility